[Musique]
bonjour joseph capron bonjour vous avez
eu la présidence de l'amm pays depuis
avril dernier dans des conditions un peu
particulières on s'en souvient à la
suite de la démission d'hervé tous et ça
y est quelques mois après vous avez pris
vos marques à cette présidence oui il
fallait bien de toutes les façons bon
cela faisait plusieurs années que j'ai
assuré la vice-présidence de
l'association donc la passation de de
flambeau entre monsieur hervé tous et
moi même s'est faite dans les meilleures
conditions possibles la hune pays
l'association martiniquaise pour la
promotion de l'industrie alors quel est
votre challenge principal pour pour ce
mandat avec votre conseil
d'administration nous en avons plusieurs
1 nous n'avons pas que seul challenge à
relever
d'abord effectivement c'est de continuer
à défendre l'industrie et les
particularités de l'industrie puisque
effectivement nous avons un certain
nombre de handicaps structurels qui font
que nous sommes confrontés a déçu au
coup d'origines diverses qui est sûr
c'est sûr que nous devons continuer
effectivement à mener un combat afin que
nous puissions obtenir et continue à
faire se pérenniser un certain nombre d'
aide dont nous disposons actuellement
comme par exemple l'aide au fret qui est
là pour compenser les surcoûts
lié aux à l'éloignement de nos sources
de matières premières et de nos sources
d'approvisionnement
également nous avons effectivement à en
termes de compétitivité
nous avons dix ont fait en face à une
concurrence souvent déloyale de
l'importation par rapport à nos sûr
qu'on salariaux je dirais entre
guillemets nous avons des salaires qui
sont un ormeau un pour dix ont un
département français d'outre-mer
mais néanmoins nous savons très bien que
toute une série de produits importés
entre à des prix bien plus disons
attractif que les nôtres et ceci étant
dû en particulier au coût de la main
d'oeuvre
donc nous devons absolument et tâche est
donc de continuer à obtenir un certain
nombre de compensation à ce sujet alors
dans votre discours hier d'ouverture
d'inauguration de ce salon made in expo
dont nous allons parler tout à l'heure
vous avez fait allusion au fait que vous
avez eu l'occasion d'échanger récemment
avec le président de la république
emmanuel macron lors de sa visite ici
ainsi qu'avec la ministre d outre mer
donc vous êtes entretenu est ce que vous
vous êtes justement comme dirait ce que
vous savez communiquer autour de ce que
vous venez de nous dire est ce que vous
avez eu l'oreille
voilà du président et de la ministre a
en tout cas et surtout des engagements
clairs oui nous nous sommes fait
entendre par exemple s'il est vrai que
nous avons eues
nous sommes obligés de subir disons la
suppression du cicr qui était disons
plus favorable pour les entreprises des
départements d'outre-mer qui sera
remplacé par des exonérations de charges
sociales mais qui pour l'instant sont
essentiellement 10 ont ciblé sur les bas
salaires
puisque vous savez que les exonérations
sont accordés pour l'instant dans la
limite de 1,4 fois le smic on nos
entreprises qui justement droit veut
faire face à la concurrence et qui
doivent également se muscler en termes
de compétences doivent quand même
recruter du personnel intermédiaires ou
du personnel d'encadrement à un niveau
de salaire quand même supérieur à 1,4
fois le smic donc tout une partie des
combats que nous menons du combat que
nous menons actuellement c'est d'obtenir
que l'on déplace disons ce curseur de
telle façon qu'il n'est pas anti plus
importante de notre masse salariale sera
concerné même si nous savons que pour
l'instant nous faisons pas anti nous
l'industrie des secteurs prioritaires
donc il faut justement nous pouvons nous
donner à priorité pour que nous
puissions recruter du personnel
disons compétents on parle souvent
justement des jeunes qui ont des
diplômes et qui ne se sent pas
réellement valoriser dans nos
entreprises
on souhaiterait bien sûr les retenir
mais il faut quand même que disons nous
ayons un minimum d'encouragement associé
john cappon président de l'apei venant à
ceux où cette made in expo qu'est ce
qu'on dit une made in expo peut-être une
exposition c'est ça c'est la cinquième
édition alors vous avez laissé le
parking du stade de dillon pour vous
déplacer à au palais des congrès de
madiana
on a l'impression d'un événement un peu
plus resserrée peut-être moins alors
qu'est-ce qu'il ya moins de sous qu'est
ce qui explique que ce choix
il ya peut-être moins d'exposants aussi
que les éditions précédentes ne sont
rien il y a un peu moins d'exposants
pense que c'est vrai que nous avons le
salon de l'habitat qui il sera disons
qu'ils très proche et il est vrai que
certains de nos adhérents ont fait le
choix de plutôt aller vers le salon de
l'habitat mais disons nous avons disons
croisille ce lieu en commun avec le la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie jeu
insiste bien sur le i de l'industrie et
nous avions pensé que la possibilité
d'avoir les conférences la proximité des
conférences des diverses réunions ça en
faisait un lieu un un peu plus convivial
que le stade de dillon alors il ya un
focus sur le l'environnement et des
énergies renouvelables
pour donc ce salon qui ne représente
alors ce secteur représente seulement à
l'heure actuelle que 11% des entreprises
industrielles martiniquaise ce secteur
de l'environnement des énergies
renouvelables là il ya un vrai potentiel
de développement pour donc le
l'industrie martiniquaise qui on a
l'impression grand rôle un peu depuis
quelques années il n'y a pas de grosses
entreprises industrielles qui qui
naissent ceci quelques temps quand
concernant l'environnement si nous avons
par exemple disons la cie dre pain qui
est dix ans qui est au coeur de cette
problématique environnementale puisque
celle usine qui est censé recycler les
bouteilles en plastique en plastique les
ans je précise qu'ils se trouvent disons
à proximité justement du stade de dillon
mais nous n'avons pas disons que l'acide
rep un spécifiquement ciblée
environnement en fait la problématique
environnementale
elle est prise en considération disons
au niveau de tous les industriels
nous avons obligation de toute façon de
ne rien jeter dans la nature de recycler
de diriger vers des filières concernées
tous nos déchets et nous le faisons
disons de façon systématique à la
problématique du recyclage
elles disent on est les au coeur de nos
activités
par exemple je prends le cas de
l'entreprise que je dirige la sacherie
capon et bien nous avons déjà entamé un
certain partenariat avec d'autres
entreprises visant à recycler tous les
films tous leurs déchets de film
plastique propre jusque pour l'instant
nous n'avons pas encore de stations de
lavage que nous
réutilisant dans notre process de
fabrication alors pour terminer alors je
disais que ça ne représente que 11% le
secteur de l'environnement des énergies
renouvelables contre 47% par exemple
pour l'agroalimentaire qui est donc le
secteur le plus important de notre
industrie
d'ailleurs un secteur ouvert à l'export
dites vous concernant l'agroalimentaire
puisque le thème c'est le succès à
l'international
oui alors le succès à l'international
effectivement qui est tout à fait
évident est tout à fait remarquable 1
dans le cas de la fille liés aux roms
rhum sucre puisque effectivement vous
savez que à l'export nous romier fondées
ont des performances qui sont quand même
remarquable et à l'heure qu'il est les
roms vieux par exemple ont une explosion
de leurs manches et c'est une croissance
à deux chiffres pour tout le monde et
bien sûr que tous les autres secteurs
leurs envies mais il n'ya pas que que le
romain nous avons également
bien sûr les exportations de la sarraz
vers les autres les autres départements
d'outre-mer et nous avons aussi
la filière travail des métaux et disons
activités tournées vers la construction
qui exportent vers les îles
environnantes
je vous aime qu'apprend on va conclure
en parlant en signalant qu'il ya un
programme de conférences à dans ce salon
made in expo qui on le rappelle l'accès
est gratuit donc des conférences grand
public notamment demain demain matin
alors il ya la remise des trophées made
in expo ça c'est traditionnel à cette
manifestation
et puis donc demain après midi à madiana
deux conférences autour de la nature
nous soigner nous nourrit voilà quand la
nature nous soigner nourrir et les
bonnes pratiques du locavore etc
voilà quelques mots sur ces thèmes-là
centre ce sont des thèmes effectivement
pas auteur dé qui montre bien que la
préoccupation pour le bien vivre et la
santé sont prises en considération par
l'industrie nous nous pensons d'ailleurs
que de plus en plus de nos industriels
tournés vers l'agroalimentaire vont
certainement chercher dans les années
qui viennent à se fait en certifié bio
d'où la nécessité effectivement de
bonnes pratiques
voilà alors par exemple demain entre 14h
et 15h30 avec le henry joseph pharmacien
et un herboriste créole est bien quand
la nature nous soignent nous nourrit de
la tradition à l'industrialisation
l'exemple du riz mais de radier je pense
que c'est une conférence qui va attirer
pas mal en 2009 en hausse dévoilé sur
sur les sites de la ccm et de la hem
pays pour se tenir informé merci josiane
capron bonne journée mais a toujours
[Musique]
oh